oh you're melting some people are worth
melting for for Kristen Bell sterling K
Brown is definitely one of them I love
me some sterling et spoke with the
predator star at comic-con where he
dished on possibly joining the cast of
frozen to there's a new character they
want to introduce that that I kind of
auditioned for and it would be an
opportunity to do something that my kid
it's definitely can watch Kristen
stepped out in LA for the premiere of
her new animated comedy Teen Titans go
to the movies so we had to ask about
sterling possibly joining the frozen
family oh I cannot comment but I love me
some sterling I'll tell you that much I
have been such a fan of Sterling's for
so long I want him in everything it's
been a big month for the blonde beauty a
new film and she just celebrated her
38th birthday oh I was so spoiled on my
birthday I well we have a rule in our
family that it's your birthday and so
you decide it's no longer your birthday
and last year I went well into September
so it's still my birthday which
basically means that I just get to make
the decisions about where we eat or I
get to leave the house for a manicure if
I feel like it it's a wonderful way to
celebrate after this I'm going to take a
workout class today because my family
went to the beach I have like an alone
day today which is unheard of I don't
have to wipe anyone's butt today I'm so
excited
you
[Music]